Ron DeSantis in his latest proof of
being completely not ready for Prime
Time ended up massively triggered at his
own press conference here and we're
going to look at a couple of clips and
the story here is this guy is so not
ready or able to handle a protracted and
and ugly National primary campaign
against Donald Trump he's just not ready
uh I don't know if he ever will be he's
so uncharismatic he's so triggleable
that uh I just don't know that he can
ever do it here DeSantis cuts off a
reporter who tries to ask him about his
anti-trans policies and DeSantis yells
out how many people here are paid or
something like that
how many of these people were paid to
come I mean like honestly it's like
seriously some of this stuff is just
totally manufactured and I when you talk
to people and I know like people in your
industry will dress it up with a
euphemism and they'll say it's it's
Health Care
to cut off the private parts of a 14 or
15 year old that is not health care that
is mutilation and so when we're standing
up against that
Sky's office rocker
kids we have Chloe Koh we've had other
people who who went through this when
they were minors now they're older and
it's like the biggest regret of their
life they feel like that they were
manipulated I understand there's some
Physicians that are very ideological
about it but the fact is people go
through a lot when they're teenagers you
grow out of it most of the time in these
situations 80 90 percent resolves by the
time you get there Sweden these European
countries that went down this road have
done a big U-turn they said this is not
good uh medical practice and so they
don't do it anymore so all we're doing
is is doing what's right
um the idea that this would have been
something that people would have been it
would have even been controversial even
like 10 years ago would not have been
something that anybody would have said
well you know what's funny is 10 years
ago the right wasn't obsessed with it
the the treatments have gotten better
but ten years ago the difference was the
right wasn't obsessed with it and in
some senses it was actually a better
process to go through and get the
treatment that people wanted to get and
that they believed was right for them in
consultation with their doctors DeSantis
asked about are you gonna run in 2024 or
not and he says relatively soon he's
going to get on that relatively soon
well look I mean I think that I was
started to get asked about this actually
years ago right but it's like look I I
was I was in my first term as Governor
we were doing good things a lot of the
stuff I was doing that I think put me on
the map was because I was getting
criticized for it especially during
covid turned out he didn't want to be in
the spotlight he was just doing the
right things and people started paying
attention that Florida handled it right
and then many other things there but I
was like look the end of the day it was
a leader you get things done very
important but you also got to show take
that case to the voters and you got to
be able to get some support on the on
the on the election front and so I felt
very confident going into November 22 we
were going to do very well but uh you
really had to put put up or shut up on
that and so we did that and I think that
that was something that was really
significant so then people have been
asking a lot after the at this is all
him pretending like he never really was
looking to run but everybody just came
to him and they were so impressed but I
also understood that we had this
opportunity here to be able to really
really do a lot of great stuff and I've
always said that we're going to see this
through and that's what we're going to
do you know what happens uh in the
future look people will will get on that
relatively soon I mean there's just you
know you either gotta put up or shut up
on that as well so what's weird is if he
says he's going to see that this through
that suggests that he would stay for the
whole gubernatorial term but clearly if
he's going to run in 2024 that's not
going to happen
um unless with the law change he's
actually going to try to be a functional
governor and right I don't know where
the guy's planning it's all crazy it's
all really really crazy
um and of course that term wouldn't be
over if he became president he would end
up leaving I don't know what he means by
we're going to see it through uh there
was then um he wrapped up with talking
about cutting off private parts which is
a classic that they now are in love with
repeating over and over again sites are
prohibited doing things like double
mastectomies they prohibited doing
things you know with uh with male
private parts that are very graphic they
prohibited pumping these miners with
puberty blockers just not something that
that it's appropriate so I think those
are appropriate guard rails look there's
some parents that this is something that
that they want to go down that road but
I think a lot of parents you know they
just want what's best for their kid
their kid may be going through something
so then they'll go to a physician and
the physician is pushing this stuff on
the family and and that's just that's
wrong and so we're happy that that we
were able to to do that remember that
they've still not demonstrated to my
satisfaction certainly that Physicians
are pushing things on people
for a lot of these folks explaining
options that exist they say that's a
form of pushing I understand
same activists were upset about the
death penalty for raping the miners
under 12. why are you upset about that
is that really the hill that you want to
die on I think some of these people that
particularly the serial abusers of these
kids I think the only appropriate
punishment is capital punishment in
those situations and kill him he's
saying kill them is he talking about
doctors who is he talking about it's
just just a little bit vague so you
can't be totally sure so we were right
to do that at and we'll continue to
continue to do what's right so all right
everybody God bless thanks so much God
bless you everybody okay yeah we're
gonna kill doctors thank you very much
now um the polling keeps getting worse
for DeSantis it's not dramatically worse
this is a 2024 Republican nomination
poll and it actually has a chart you see
that the second line here this DeSantis
line it peaked uh in mid-February and
then got almost back up there in late
March but there's been this pretty
significant decline quite frankly the
decline started right before Trump got
arrested and and then did get arrested
um continuing to kind of stick between
DeSantis was between 23 and 24 for a
while in the primary polling remember
this is against Trump he's now down
between 22 and 23. so the polling's
getting worse not dramatically worse but
it really doesn't seem like this guy has
what it takes and it's so easy to get
under his skin I hope he does run
because I think it's better for the
Democratic nominee and it's worse for
DeSantis and it's worse for Trump if
you're looking for the perfect Mother's
Day gift our sponsor Aura frames creates
incredible Ultra quality digital frames
we're displaying pictures and videos you
can pre-load the frame with your
favorite memories pictures videos for
Mom to see when she opens it up you can
update it with unlimited photos and
videos from anywhere using the aura
frames app no fees ever no limits on
storage Aura frames was voted the number
one digital picture frame by wire cutter
the strategist and Wired Magazine my mom
loves the frame I gave her I also have
an aura frame in my house when we were
just traveling I was able to immediately
add pictures which pop up on my mom's
frame and I've noticed the photos look
like real prints such high resolution
and the display is calibrated so that
you can not even tell it to screen Aura
frames has an awesome Mother's Day deal
for my audience you'll get up to thirty
dollars off their best-selling Carver
map frame and free shipping go to
auraframes.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description